this simple crowdwork trick is a game  changer i know from personal experience  that crowd work is not easy  just had a flashback but this trick will  help it be more fun in my previous video  i dissected adam ray's listening  technique with crowd work but this video  dives into how he uses characters adam  has just asked a stone audience member  what his name is and after a five second  delay what's your name dude  yeah you [ __ ] forgot see how high  this guy is  if that's not a commercial for don't  smoke weed kids  what's your name here to think about uh  well give me a second dude what's with  the pop quiz and now that adam has  established the absurdity he can now  heighten it with hypothetical characters  yeah [ __ ] too late dude  you just asked your friend by the way  characters and crowd work are a match  made in comedy heaven which is why i  believe